My name is Patricia Spears Jones.
The poem is “Lave.”
Where is the lavender,
the purple scent
that says the world is fresh
and ready to receive
the woman who walks into whatever room
she walks into.
What room will she enter?
How will the female worker smell?
Lemon, mint,
roses crushed for homemade soap.
No place
here for the boiling recipe.
There is no room.
And her extra money,
how will she make it?
Who will she do for?
How will she get there?
Will she find her old friends, her lovers?
She is lonely.
The artist says in Panel 57
that the female worker
(not Negro,
not migrant)
is the last group to leave the South.
One woman is her own group?
Was she ready to leave or was she
left behind?
Caring for: baby, grandfather
brother, sister, cousin,
an elderly aunt?
Was her garden
where the family sought nurture?
Were her skills
at picking cotton so great
the bosses did
all they could to keep her?
Was there a fourth child,
not wished for?
Much about the South
is unseen or not shown—
the painter understands
the usefulness of obscenity
lynching, hunger,
the crops failing
(boll weevil, boll weevil).
And so we see the cotton ball
but not the bleeding hands that pick.
We see the rope dangling.
We see the meager rations of meat
and bread.
And the table set—no plenty.
Is this the start
of a woman’s true blues?
The men go ahead.
The women stay behind
and everyone is lonely?
In many of the painting’s planes,
she is not seen
preparing the meals, cleaning,
sewing, packing clothes
to last for as long as they can last
in the distant cities of
Chicago, Pittsburgh, Detroit.
She is not seen crying
at the preacher’s table
or burying her head into the broad chest
of the man
who gets up before sunrise
to make it to the station
ticket in hand.
The men knew the hardships ahead,
others were ignorant
enough to believe the stories of plenty:
WORK FOOD SHELTER.
Women put no truck
in these White men’s promises.
They
wanted out of Dixie
on a very bad day. Wanted out of stuck.
She will leave for the north
and go to the cities.
She will find
the church where her bible meets
the preacher’s Holy hollering
and the music sounds as sweet
as in the back-woods.
She will see the kind of dresses
she wanted to make
from the Butterick patterns
at the notions counter,
the same counter
where she finds the yellow ribbons
that tie the braids
of the young girl in Painting 21
who arrived early
to get on that North bound train.
Is this the start
of another woman’s blues
to journey north and find the men mired?
To journey north
and find her skills unknown?
and discover an even greater loneliness?
The female worker gets that ticket
and joins that motion forward—
the many shoulders, legs,
hands stretched across
the paintings’ frames
counting
the rails away,
away, away from Dixie Land.
Head bowed, holding an orange dolly,
the laundress is charged with purgation,
removing the dust
and dirt and stains of city living
the marks of many sins: sex, drink,
the opium den.
These swirling oblongs
colors rest
beneath her gaze
as if she has the power
to make this job seem better than
picking cotton or hog butchering
or taking
in washing for the old gentleman
who pinches her breasts for that extra
nickel.
Last to arrive north.
But first to see the way home,
to make a home.
Put her skillets on the hot plate;
shelves her mason jars
full of peach preserves,
pickles, tastes of home.
Chenille spreads on the lumpy mattresses
the Chicago Defender on a kitchen table.
Biscuits rising before sunrise.
Greens found in an Italian market.
She stands in this painting
a cruciform of desire
in a center of beauty
dressed in white,
the orange stick,
her cudgel,
her sword,
the laundry
her step on that ladder to the future.
A migrant from the back of the bottom
or a town just big enough
for the railroad to notice
gone to the city
and its bitter possibilities
so that
church is a hearthstone
and eau de cologne—
lavender, roses,
vanilla, hints of —
a necessity.